according to a new article on Melania
Trump that just came out most evenings
Melania does not have dinner with
President Trump yeah
Melania said occasionally I'll join him
during his third breakfast but just
shoveling just shoveling I love all this
Rudy Guiliani stuff now Rudy Giuliani is
now acting as Trump's lawyer and he's
just like a sprinkler saying anything
yeah yeah yeah he's just saying stuff
left and right Rudy Giuliani was on TV
this weekend he said President Trump may
take the fifth yeah yeah it's unclear if
Giuliani is referring to amendments or
wives
[Applause]
today Sarah Huckabee Sanders said she is
unaware of hush money payments made by
President Trump to other women yeah then
Sanders opened an envelope full of cash
and said I'm sorry
I can't talk anymore thank you thank you
for us
to dwell in that section over there I
don't know I don't know why during their
recent summit the South Korean president
gave North Korean leader Kim jong-un a
USB Drive yeah Kim jong-un said thank
you this looks delicious behind on that
technology on Saturday Elon Musk tweeted
that he wants to start a candy company
yeah and today Eli must tweeted that his
candy company is already three months
behind in production so yeah Electric
candy on Friday a man in Wisconsin broke
a world record by eating his 30,000th
Big Mac 30,000 Big Mac yeah meanwhile
another man broke a world record by
eating at Long John Silver's twice
Long John Silver's jokes always work
I've never eaten there oh I'm never
telling my [ __ ] on that place people
like ya I'm not even sure they still
exam they not exactly honest yeah well
John Silver's if you're out there I'm
sorry but they work every time
you